MAX SALTONSTALL: With almost
500 sessions of Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Don't Get Phished--
Authentication Best
Practices, then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Listen, nobody actually
likes passwords.
They're hard to
remember, easy to lose,
and don't protect
us all that well.
Not to mention,
people are really
bad at picking passwords too.
I mean, just look at the most
popular passwords in 2015.
Not very hard to
guess, are they?
Have you used one of these?
If not, I bet some of the
people you're trying to protect
are using them right now.
And 2018 doesn't
really get much better.
Maybe we shouldn't
be trusting people
to keep passwords safe at all.
Turns out they aren't very good
at resisting phishing attempts.
It's especially
easy to get someone
to fall prey to a phishing
attack with a false sense
of urgency, such as a fake
"your account is at risk" email.
Then, somebody will
spend less time checking
for signs of a fake site and
just rush to complete the form.
To help keep you and
your people safe,
Google will stop these
login attempts automatically
when we notice the
pattern deviates
from your normal behavior.
But it's not perfect.
This problem is better suited
to a hardware and software
solution.
And Google has some ideas to
make the password both safer
and less critical to
the login process.
To start, adding any second
factor is better than none
at all.
Many people use a
one-time password already.
And that is a
security improvement.
But these are still
phishable, especially via SMS.
And the physical fobs that
give you a six-digit code
are expensive and fragile.
Besides, if you've seen
that friend carrying
10 or 20 fobs on a
necklace just to get access
to the various systems
they use at work,
you can see how
it doesn't scale.
We prefer security key as
a second layer of defense
in front of your account.
The keys use open
cryptography standards
similar to public key
encryption and are
physical devices
like this, which
you register to your account and
use to prove that you are you.
When you're logging
in, the security key
does two important things.
One, it tells a server
that a person actually
sat at the keyboard
for this login
because you have to touch
the key to activate it.
So we can stop automated
script-based attacks.
Two, it goes to a challenge
response handshake
with the server and will
only complete a login
with the appropriate back end.
So if you go to a cleverly
disguised phishing
site that tries to steal
your login credentials,
the security key will
fail to authenticate you.
We've mandated security keys
for all Google employees.
And they've shown
tremendous effectiveness
at preventing
account compromise.
We also see a faster
time to login.
So we're actually making people
more efficient and more secure
at the same time.
And we see fewer support
incidents with security keys
compared to one-time
password fobs.
Lucky for you, the exact same
capabilities can be yours.
G Suite administrators can
enable or require security keys
for accounts in your domain.
We highly recommend
security keys
to help you secure your
high-value accounts,
including executives
and domain super admins.
To learn more about how
you can use security keys,
how Google secures
employee accounts,
and to see an exciting
new kind of security key,
check out the link
in the description
below for the full talk.
Thanks for watching.
Subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more Next Rewind
videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]